[Applaus]
entschuldigung wenn ich sie anspreche
aber hat ihn schon mal jemand sagt sie
strahlend aus wieder grünwald der gewinn
bei 1000 fernseher danke dann wirklich
wie aus dem gesicht geschnitten zu
verwechseln ähnlich waren er ist günter
grünwald bin nein doch
wirklich ja wirklich nein doch nein doch
wenn ich sehr nah doch sorgen als er
gewisse ähnlichkeit ja aber ein problem
weil zum beispiel der ja doch ganz
andere in rosenheim
schlanker ist der auch bitter und locker
zehn jahre jünger erscheinen das passt
oder nicht ich
also wenn sie die günter grünwald in der
bericht der kaiser von china
entschuldigen wieder richtig einfach so
ansprechen hat ihn schon mal jemand
gesagt also sie sehen aus wie der kaiser
von china
nein wirklich wir haben schon von der
ganz hinten gesagt ich hab zu meiner
freundin der sieht doch aus wie der
kaiser von china das mit gare dass sich
der kaiser von china
ich dachte der kaiser von china welche
ehre was versteht kaiserlicher denn zu
uns nach bayern einkaufen vielleicht ein
paar neuen hinweisen
sie sehen ja aus wie
aus dem gesicht geschnitten wie zu
verwechseln ähnlich aber er ist es nicht
schauen sie doch einmal die nasen und
den bauch ich sorglos grund das ist der
echte grünwald ist viel jünger zehn
jahre locker
ich bin günter grünwald sorgen jetzt hat
das ist schon sehr
noch irgendwelche fragen also ich es
doch gut per
eines
ausland
so ein ungehobelter unangenehmer klotz
kommen sie kaiserliche hoheit so ein
umgang haben sie nicht verdient so ein
primitiver eingebildet hat und nur wer
bis zum laufschuh grünwoldt
[Applaus]